i think it's safe to say uh martin short
is the best late night guest of all time
i think that's fair fair the only
murders in the building star graced
everyone with his appearance on the
tonight show and nothing was off limit
yes our canadian legend and emmy nominee
did not disappoint as he unleashed some
brutal jokes about his co-star steve
martin kim kardashian and pete davidson
the trump family and so much more
james thomas fallon yes my god your name
screams out diversity it really does
do i regret my uh kim and pete forever
tattoo sure um
[Applause]
absolutely you can fix your friends i've
had a few do i yes i do you know how
about this you know i was at the i was
at mar-a-lago during the big fbi raid
wait what oh i'm gonna lie you know no
no i'm i'm i'm a member i did not know
you remember
god well i i don't like trump's politics
but i love his omelette station no that
makes sense well that's it's
beautiful and you know it's so great
because you can just if you remember you
can just read as many classified
documents as you want they're on they're
all scattered everywhere i didn't even
know you knew the trumps oh i know the
trumps i used to babysit the kids for
god's sake
eric and don jr we would play monopoly
but their version is the winner is the
first person to yell bankruptcy
[Applause]
what have you learned touring with steve
martin
well
i've learned that he will pay top dollar
for clean urine um
you got to pass those tests
i've learned that from him that you
don't need to have a pool to have a pool
boy but you know steve and i are
nominated and uh you know
if i can't win i hope he wins but i can
win so screw him you know no no no i
thought that's not weird no that's not
but it mean you are nominated for the
exact same category i know so yeah i
mean you have to
you either win or you you if you if you
lose do you have a well if if i lose i'm
going to send will smith up to slap him
no no no no no you got to kill him
he won't be there he won't be there for
the thing here's what's amazing here's
what's amazing if someone had told me
20 years ago
that i would be on the tonight show with
jimmy fallon with all these emmy
nominations i would have said
jimmy fallon
[Laughter]
[Music]
the delivery the best
the go driver this guy is so sharp so
sharp so funny like all the time have
you ever interviewed martin shorts no
even in those short like junket
interviews that we do that like four
minutes long five minutes
he's on yeah the entire time he'll find
something about you anything like he's
just
dude so funny so while i'm watching that
one of the first things that popped into
my head was well he needs to host an
award show or how many award shows has
he hosted in the past and i i mean maybe
this came around and i missed this news
but selena gomez steve martin and martin
short were asked to host the oscars but
apparently scheduling got in the way can
you just imagine how epic that was i'm
still holding out for that so i'm just
putting that in the universe you want
that out there you want it happening
because there's something so
he's not nasty you know and there's this
fine line in comedy now you know like
where's you know how far is too far what
can you joke about what can't you joke
about but he can literally get away with
saying anything i mean he's so funny he
goes
right up to the line and the lines that
he crosses are like lines that are like
feel like they're okay to cross a little
bit like especially if it's you know
he's joking about jimmy fallon with
jimmy fallon yeah right like it's
something like that and he's not being
nasty about it exactly is it the
canadian in him maybe it's the community
you know what i mean it's like you can't
get mad at him there's something kind of
so endearing about him depending on what
he says uh june is saying martin short
is always hilarious so will studios are
saying martin short is a canadian gem a
true treasure hilarious and so smart uh
keith gordon saying you don't need a
pool to have a full ball yeah
i think our camera guy katarina laughed
at that one my guy threw shade at his
guy
immediately
it's so good
so yeah i would like to see
more of that they're on the road
yes is that what he was saying yes steve
martin martin short together let's get
them tickets let's go
go to that very cool